So here is a particle that was shot through
and it's knocked an electron out of an atom.
And by having a magnetic field around the
bubble chamber
it bends the path of the electron
because the electron is negatively charged.
Things don't change direction of their own
accord.
Things like to go in a straight line unless
you influence them.
If you make a magnetic field, negatively charged
particles will go one way,
and positives the other.
Neutral particles don't leave any trail at
all in these pictures.
Now let's look at the next picture.
If you really turn on the magnetic field,
your electron will spiral round and round
and round and round.
As it slows down the spiral gets tighter and
tighter and tighter.
It looks like the picture of a snail from
the top or something like that.
Now let's look at the next one.
Now this has got a lot of information. It's
a beautiful picture.
At this point here an electron's been knocked
out of the atom
and shoots off very high speed curving very
slightly.
I know it's high speed because when you go
fast you only curve a little bit.
If you go slow, you'll curve all the way around
when you get given the sideways kick.
But look at this. Here's an electron that
started off slow.
It's really gone into a very tight spiral.
But on the other side there's the same thing
going the other way.
Negatively charged particles go one way, positives
go the other.
This, the red trail at the bottom, is a positively
charged electron.
The exact mirror image of the regular negative
electron.
It's an example of antimatter.
Captured here on film.
This is antimatter, it's as real as the electrons
are real.
Now over here, an electron and its antimatter
partner,
which is called a positron by the way, is
produced.
But between here and here, nothing appears
to have happened.
These appear to have appeared out of nowhere.
Well that doesn't make sense at all.
What's happened is that something without
any charge at all
has gone from here to here and left no trail.
But we recognise he was there the moment it
did this.
So, we've got the steps in deciphering the
pictures,
Let's look at out original picture again and
see if we can make sense of it.
OK, well this very faint circle here is just
an electron kicked out of an atom.
Like the first part of our three pieces of
the jigsaw puzzle.
At this point here we see a whole series of
negatively charged particles
curving off that way, and positives curving
off the other way.
Then there's a gap where something without
any charge at all must have gone
And it reveals its presence when it turns
into two particles that do reveal themselves.
So, that shows you how you begin to decipher
the picture.
But in this picture there's something very
interesting. This gap here.
A particle without any charge must have lived
and for a very, very short time.
Let me show you what I mean.
I've got this little clock along the bottom.
This is the spot where this neutral object
was created.
And that's where it died.
Now what's this clock doing?
Let's just think what happens in this thing
here.
We've got this bubble chamber and the camera
taking photographs.
There's particles shooting in from one side,
almost at the speed of light.
They are across the bubble chamber in a flash.
But the camera takes the picture, it's probably
for a thousanth of a second.
Which is a short time to you and me,
but it's a long time to a particle that is
moving near the speed of light.
It's as if the particle enters this side of
the bubble chamber and the clock starts.
By the time it's got to here, the clock is
just passed the starting point.
By the time it's got to here, it's a millionth
of a second later.
By the time it's got to here it's four millionths
of a second later
and then it exits on the other side.
But the camera shutter has been open all the
time.
And it takes what appears to be a still photograph
as you see here.
But in fact it's a timelapse.
The time is running from one side to the other.
So between here and here it's maybe a millionth
of a second or less.
So this picture has captured the passage,
the life and death of a particle,
that lives for less than a millionth of a
second.
It's astonishing to think that with this simple
device
you can capture short, short timescales and
make them for real.
And that is as important a part of the universe
as everything else.
We've suddenly opened up sections in time
here.
With our naked eye we can see a rainbow from
red to purple
but we can expand right the way across the
electromagnetic spectrum
and see the great universe out there.
Here suddenly we've expanded our senses in
time to the very, very short.
These new unexpected short-lived particles
are as relevant to the universe,
are as real to the whole picture, as the things
that live long enough to make you and me.
And any rational explanation of the totality
must include them.
And that's the big challenge.